I'm taking notes on on a lecture right
now. I'm learning about American and
British Empire. You're talking about the
British Empire. Yeah. You need to start
doing drugs again and denounce Islam.
Denounce Islam and do drugs again. What
an absolute [__]
I want to invite you to add something
powerful to your Sadaqah Jariyah list.
We're on a mission to teach tens of
thousands of people around the world
>> how to pray salah properly. Just imagine
this. You help someone learn with you
how to pray. How to recite Surah
Al-Fatiha. Every Fajr, Dhuhr, Asr,
Maghrib, Isha, Tahajjud,
>> Tarawih, every prayer for the rest of
their lives, you share in the reward.
>> When they teach their children, and
their children's children,
the reward continues for you.
>> For just £100, you can help teach 20 to
60 people
>> like me learn salah. Donate today and
earn rewards that never stop.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. I came across a video of Sneako
doing a live talking about the prophet
Muhammad about the war that's going on
between Iran, USA, and Israel, which
seems like so far Iran, the fact that
it's surviving and hitting Israel US
bases is winning this war. However, in
the middle of that, an individual called
Clavicula, if I think that's what his
name is, who my brother brother Dawud
has been telling me a lot about him. I
was like, "Who's this clown?" etc.
Clavicula is his name. He's known for
his looks maxing. I think that's what
it's called. But he believes that the
more handsome, the more better you look,
etc., you can do better in
the worldly life, etc. And I'm going to
say to me, actually he's right. You
know, because at the end of the studies
that show a person who's a good-looking
person, people tend to believe him more
and accept him more. But in the sight of
God, it's nothing. Because once Abdullah
ibn Mas'ud, if I'm not mistaken,
Abdullah ibn Abbas, was on a tree and
some of the Sahabah laughed at him. They
said, "Look at his skinny legs." And the
Prophet said, "For by Allah, his weight
is in the sight of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala heavier than Mount Uhud. In the
sight of Allah, it's what matters.
Because the people that are giving you
this thing and you're going to get easy
way of life doesn't mean you're going to
find happiness or peace. Let's watch
this video and let's see what this
absolute clown had to say and he made a
little joke about Islam. But listen,
he's sat there with four girls half
naked in their bras or whatever it is
for that matter. Let's watch for
ourselves. What up clown? What you up
to?
It's Nico. Hey,
what's up?
>> Nico. Nico.
What are you What are you top 10 holy
What are you guys up to?
>> Okay, so we just wanted to
We just wanted to say what's up cuz I
heard you were on Monkey Jizz or Maxin
so I was like all right, let me
let me just and hop in this guy's
segment real quick. I'm I'm Cuz either
that or I I gamble. I'm taking notes on
on a lecture. Okay, so far fantastic.
He's got uh um He's got half naked girls
sexually objectified cuz the West loves
empowerment of the woman. Feminism is
there to give you the sexual liberation
for men. Thank you very much feminists.
You've done a fantastic job by
dehumanizing women and alhamdulillah and
dropping them to a level when they're
nothing but sexual objects. So much so
it's like If you think about it, why do
we go to the toilet to relieve Why do we
go to the toilet? To relieve ourselves.
Number one and number two. And guess
what men do with women? We go inside
them They go inside them to relieve
theirself like inanimate objects. What's
he saying? Oh, if I was not doing this,
I was going to go gamble. What's an
amazing degeneracy you have? I'm either
going to be here sleeping with these
women who Can you imagine they're going
to have future husbands? They're on
sitting on a lap of a man and another
man one day is going to marry this
woman. Audhubillah. And he's going to
gamble. What a fantastic way of life.
Let's carry on. Right now I'm learning
about American and British Empire.
You're talking about the British Empire?
Yeah. You need to start doing drugs
again and denounce Islam. Okay, perfect.
He's He's called Siko to something
fantastic.
Denounce Islam and do drugs again. What
an absolute [__]
What's his name? The vascular? So I
don't give a damn what his name is.
Clavicular, testicular, muscular, uh no
testicles testicular. I don't give a
damn. Okay, leave Islam and do drugs.
Fantastic. And I'm not going to do that,
bro. Never going to happen.
Alhamdulillah. May Allah keep Sneako
firm.
>> [laughter]
>> No, I'm just kidding. But anyway, how
was your night? How's the looks maxing
going? Ladies, how you doing? Good. How
are you? Yeah, I'm good. So, these are
um
You just some that I uh popped out with
Check this Check this out. These are
some Excuse my language. It's Ramadan. B
I T C H and hoes. And And they're there
like, "Yeah, yes, me, yeah." In the
club, you know, I remember in
Jahiliyyah, you'll see girls partying
saying, "Yeah, I'm that bad hoe. I'm
that bad this." And then you've got
radical hijabi feminists now saying,
"I'm a baddie. I'm a baddie." What
absolute utter
jokes. Wallahi al-Azim. Subhanallah. All
right, she's a [__] though. So
Um did you do it Did you do it uh check?
She we actually did and she actually
like pulled out her and almost got me
banned. Look at this. Look at Look how
they dehumanize women. Look how vile
they are towards women. And we as It's
in Islam, we honor women. Women are
human beings. Look how they She's
literally insulting them, calling them
names. And they're like, "Yeah, that's
us. That's us." Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> It was like It was a crazy stream. Crazy
stream. With hair and No, Sneako's too
quiet. Make him louder. Hey, W, bro.
All right, yeah, but so we basically
were around tonight doing a yacht. You
got to get back to Miami. Yeah, where
Where are you staying? I'm in New York
right now. It's uh starting to get a
little warmer, you know, but it's been
It's just been inside. Wait till the
harem is 24, right, Sneako? Well, you
have to get married to them. It's not
just uh a harem, but But is it four? It
is four, though, right?
>> Well, I think it's like 99% of Muslims
have one wife or in a monogamous
>> No, no, but is it Is that like the
number four of for a harem? Well, that's
the maximum amount you can have, yeah.
The maximum, good. I'll throw this off
the balcony so quick. Okay, interesting.
So, he's got five there. So, he's
saying, "I'm going to throw this one off
the balcony." And so, he's taking the
mickey out of Islam. Islam has come to
honor women. They're not sexual objects
like you. He uses the word haram or
whatever it is where he says it, yeah?
So you can see how he's mocking Islam.
Well, Islam has come to give rights to
those women to be treated to be looked
after, treated equally, given rights,
honored, married, spoken to their
fathers, etc. Okay, looked after. Look
how he's there, got these three four
half-naked girls who are being
exploited, sexually objectified girls.
And this is what the West makes them,
okay? Alhamdulillah for Islam. All
right, I'll I'll make you
Transgenders are not allowed. You're not
supposed to have uh
No, he looks like a She looks like a
dude.
Maybe you're afraid of homo. You have a
lot of tattoos, but
you don't look like a man. Yeah, you do
not look like a dude.
She doesn't look like a dude, that's
true.
Okay, all right, open it.
All right, he's about to send
How do I Oh, yeah, okay, wait, right
now? Damn, [__] Hold on, Sneako, pull
up my stream.
You're just ear maxing for for 10 viewer
Kick streamers.
10 viewers, nine bots, no chat activity.
That's That's who you're being a groupie
for.
All right, Kick groupie. We already have
Alice, we don't need another one.
>> [laughter]
>> Look at that, whoops, busted.
What? Who are you a groupie for?
Huh? Who is she a groupie for?
Uh 50 viewer Kick streamers. I couldn't
even tell you the name, exactly.
Sneako, you got to start going IRL more.
Or how how old are you, ladies?
Oh, don't ask that question. All right,
mute, mute, mute. I'll tell you off
stream. Well, I won't be surprised, I
mean, most of the pedophiles look like
you. So, to be honest, I won't be
surprised they don't want to tell their
age, yeah? Subhanallah, okay. Yeah, that
I we're streaming with Theo Mike, so if
that answers your question.
The guy right behind you from before
that I was gambling. I'm just kidding,
they're all 21. I deed them all, so
All right.
What?
I'm not mad. I don't get
No, I'm actually feeling really good.
I've got this hot girl on my
All right, you guys have have fun. Have
fun tonight, okay?
Okay, yeah. I mean, obviously I would
obviously say he was in that sphere etc.
I would personally say don't even get
engaged with these degenerates. As you
can see, can you just imagine? This is
why the
the Western man is in depression. You
know why? Because by the time he marries
his wife, his wife's been with 19, 20,
25 different men. Can you just imagine?
25 different men have
penetrated your wife, sitting on their
lap. That's why they can't control.
They've they've destroyed them. That's
why they're unhappy. That's why they're
not in peace. And they are jealous. They
think we're jealous in their worldview.
No one in the Muslim world is jealous of
the Western world. With all due respect,
with your degeneracy, gambling, alcohol
addiction, drug addiction, sex outside
of marriage, you name it. Look at this
degeneracy. Four women there, and he's
calling them hoes. And they're like,
"Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're the hoes, etc."
Wallahi, Islam has come to honor women.
And this is why women are flocking to
Islam. That is another person's wife
there. And look how the system has given
them dawah in the sense of their
fake degenerate dawah, calling them to
this way of life. And those women are so
brainwashed that they accepted it, and
they call their self, "We're a hoe. I'm
I'm a hoe." That's what they say to
their self. "I'm a hoe." Can you imagine
how low in society you have to be? Lower
than low. That's subhanallah. But you
name yourself, you give yourself a
derogatory title like that. And there's
this dirtbag gambling, do drugs, do
this, etc. Wallahi, that's why Islam is
the truth. And that's why Islam came to
honor women. Where in the Arabian
Peninsula, they were treated like this.
Where girls were buried alive. And Allah
says in the Quran that the girl would on
the day of judgment say, "For what crime
did you kill me?" Okay? And that's why
alhamdulillah for Islam brothers and
sisters, there's so many women coming to
Islam. And we as a organization, we
teach them how to pray salah with our
one-to-one salah instructors for both
brothers and sisters team. We have
guided prayer mats that we've given out
80,000 and we're printing another 70,000
in Italian, German, French, Spanish,
Japanese, English that will be
distributed to dowaties, to mosques, to
prisons, to schools, to hospitals, to
universities. Brothers and sisters,
alhamdulillah for free. We have salah
pro app that's been downloaded by 70,000
people and plus more where your
donations will go and we have the salah
hubs where we work with masajid that
register on our app and they do salah
classes for reverts and anyone that
doesn't know how to pray salah to go. We
diversify your sadaqah jariya. In
Ramadan, this could be on that odd
night. I've shown you the proof in the
pudding. Go to the link and see exactly
where your donation is going, brothers
and sisters, and make sure, brothers and
sisters, that you invest in the
hereafter and don't be a loser. He's
going to get the dunya but he's going to
lose the akhirah. Be among those and we
ask Allah to guide him to Islam and he
changes his ways. But be those who,
subhanallah, are waiting in the sight of
Allah subhanallah ta'ala, not in the
dunya because the dunya is going to
perish. Everything he owns is going to
perish. Nothing the prophet sala allahu
alayhi wasallam said, "When a person
dies, he takes three things towards the
grave. His family, his wealth, and his
deeds. Two leave and one stay. His
family and his wealth go back and the
only thing that stays is his deeds." Be
among those people, brothers and
sisters. Go to the link and donate to
the salah pro project and diversify your
sadaqah jariya. I'll call myself an FAA
financial akhirah advisor. I've given
you the advice. Invest where it matters.
Clavicula, I challenge you to a debate.
Let's talk about this. Islam or the
Western world. Till next time,
assalamualaikum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh. This is the new sadaqah
jariya in town.
>> Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
the Quran
>> a man pleading with Allah to send him
back so he could give sadaqah. Why
sadaqah? Because he knows the weight of
sadaqah. Just 100 pounds you can help
teach 20 to 60 people to learn
>> how to perform salah recite surah fatiha
and make wudu. Click the link and donate
now.